bienvenue dans afrique honnête sur 45
pays d'afrique subsaharienne 28
interdisent ou réprime l'homosexualité
par mire les pays les plus radicaux on
peut citer l'ouganda le ghana le
cameroun le nigeria où la lapidation et
même pratiqué à l'encontre dès personnes
homosexuelles dans plusieurs états du
nord du pays à la lutte pour les droits
de la communauté lgbt cuit un combat
risqués et courageuse sur le continent
justement se connectent depuis douala
avec notre invité allison comme
opposante première femme avocate au
cameroun et défenseur des droits lgbt
fondatrice de la première ong anti
homophobie au cameroun l'adefho
l'association pour la défense des droits
des homosexuels
ah bonjour m une com merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans afrique
connecte sur arte france
bonjour et bonne année et je suis
j'ai vraiment vraiment me tient à coeur
et
alors justement pourquoi vous avez
choisi de dédier votre vie
professionnelle à la lutte pour la
légalisation de l'homosexualité en
afrique
j'ai décidé de m'occuper de ces droits
de l'homme
et droits des homosexuels sont les
droits de l'homme
lorsque j'ai vu à chaque audience des
flagrants délits et je dois enchaîner
poursuivez pour homosexualité au début
je n'ai pas prêté attention parce que
effectivement de côté
c'était hopper avait un article de
passants
qui s'appelait homosexualité qui de fait
qui définissent l homosexualité comme
étant le fait pour une personne de d'un
truc tenir ou d'avoir un rapport sexuel
avec une personne de même sexe les
bennes était de 6 mois à 5 ans et je me
disais bon ben c'est un délit
et puis je prends leur prochain en fait
c'était comment les avait vus je tenais
pas sur la route ou
marché comme des femmes ainsi de suite
de petites choses bizarres qui ont qui
ont quand même interpellé l'avocat le
juriste cité et puis un jour dans les
années 2002 je reçoit la visite de
quatre jeunes gens qui viennent me
saluer c'était des français des
patriciens et il est camerounais
d'origine ne quittais arrivée en france
qui passait des vacances ici avec leurs
camarades leurs amis et là me parlant
j'ai compris qu'ils étaient un peu plus
que des amis et si les gens entre voir
ce que je vois à savoir qu'ils sont
homosexuels il peut leur arriver de tous
les malheurs ils peuvent être agressés
arrêtés
battus enfin bref tout cela va être
raisonnée et je me suis posé la question
très rapidement qu'est ce que je fais je
le redis faire attention parce que si
c'est des gens qui venaient de paris ou
de france où ils vivaient normalement
leur sexualité ça se soucier de savoir
si les gens les regardent elle puisque
l'homosexualité n'est plus pénalisée au
cameroun alors finalement j'ai dit je
dois leur dire ça parce qu'un homme
averti en vaut deux et que j'ai le droit
d'informer je suis là pour conseiller
également mais comment faire alors je me
dis que je m'excusais que j'étais pas
tout à fait comme humeur que j'avais des
problèmes parce que j'avais un dossier
qui me titille cachet c'était un
monsieur
d'homosexualité parce que
l'homosexualité au cameroun était un
délit je leur avais envoyé sur le le
ciel sur la tête il a j'ai compris que
j'avais tous ces justes et d'ailleurs la
douzième du dit lui avait totalement
disparu de leurs visages et je crois
qu'ils ont interrompu la durée de la
visite qu'ils avaient promis de faire
avec moi et pour que je les conseille
plutôt sur les projets qui étaient les
leurs et quand ils m'ont dit au revoir
l'étude de regards et j'ai vu avec
beaucoup de duels beaucoup de désolation
que j'avais je n'aime pas bien là que
j'avais interrompre une joie qui je
n'avais pas le droit de faire et la
tristesse qui solides sur leurs yeux
personnes désemparées en plein désarroi
michael jusqu'à la maison le soir je
voudrais vous entendre sur le discours
structuré justement autour de
l'homosexualité de l'homophobie en
afrique sur l'homosexualité ce qui se
dit c'est que c'est une pratique qui
vient des sociétés occidentales en
opposition à ceux qui affirment que dans
l'afrique précoloniale et bien
l'homosexualité était toléré et
concernant le mobile encore deux
versions elle est ancrée dans la culture
africaine et pour d'autres c'est un
héritage de post coloniale issues du
christianisme
l'article qui punit l'homosexualité au
cameroun etienne l'article qui qui a été
introduit dans le code pénal par voie
d'ordonnancé déjà une faute parce que
les problèmes concernant
les crimes et délits dans la
constitution sont du domaine de la loi
et non pas
d'une ordonnance c'est à dire de l'eau
de l'exécutif alors déjà cette
ordonnance date du mois de septembre
1972 dans un code pénal qui était là
depuis
et cet article s'appelait l'article 347
bis ça veut bien dire qu'il est arrivé
après et il s'est mis à côté un autre
article qui existait avant qu'ils
n'avaient rien à voir avec le mot
sexualité déjà cette chronologie d'un
pays comme le gamou nous on sait que le
cameroun est indépendant depuis 1960 à
1965 le cameroun s'est dotée de son
premier quinquennat
et dans ce code pénal qui est une loi
votée par les parlementaires
qui venaient de tous les coins et
recoins
du cameroun les coins les plus reculés
nous sommes en 1965 nous n'avons pas de
télévision nous n'avons pas de téléphone
donc sept députés sont des gens père war
seals avaient dans leur tête l'idée du
une homosexualité qu'ils vivent comme un
délit ou quelque chose de contraire à
l'harmonie dans la société s'il vivait
ça comme un acte qui une fois posé cause
un préjudice à la personne ou aux biens
d'autrui eh bien ils auraient voté cette
loi là en 1965
non ils ne l'ont pas fait il a fallu que
le président de la république en 1972
qui les eaux de son palais il une
ordonnance qui viole le principe de la
séparation des pouvoirs et inscrire dans
la constitution
l'homophobie à un mètre en camouflant
problème qui est lié à la culture
africaine spécifiquement pas du tout pas
du tout soutien de vous expliquer que si
c'était lié à la culture africaine je
pense que les députés du cameroun à 1966
alors et discuté et on nous refait un
délit mais ça n'a pas été le cas or un
milieu sain sur le sachet et jusqu'en
1972 en france l angleterre ou en
allemagne par tout à l'euro
l'homosexualité est un délit mais tout
comme principale conséquence de
l'homophobie c'est un niveau de violence
et de persécution élevé comme lors de
cette vague homophobes au ghana en 2021
qui avait d'ailleurs suscité l'émoi
international les nouveaux locaux de
l'association que vous connaissez lgbt
qu ils rights ghana a créé en 2018 ont
été visés les locaux ont dû fermer après
une perquisition à des forces de l'ordre
on va écouter justement à le directeur
de l'association alex koffi condat en
2021 nous avons fait l'objet d'une très
forte attaque notamment de la part de
l'état lorsque nous avons ouvert un
centre communautaire pour fournir des
services tels que de l'aide
psychosociale juridique et sanitaires
ainsi qu'une formation à
l'autonomisation des personnes lgbt q
mais lorsque nous avons ouvert cet
espace nous avons été confrontés à un
niveau très élevé de violence et de
discrimination à notre égard
pour que finalement la sécurité
nationale la police les médias et
certains leaders religieux encerclent
notre bureau et nous fassent fermer
c'était aussi une occasion pour nous
d'exprimer notre mécontentement et les
abus continuent que nous subissons en
tant qu'individu et en tant qu
organisation qui s'occupe des intérêts
des personnes lgbt qu au ghana
m comme je sais que vous êtes passé par
là parce que vous avez vous aussi créé
en 2003 votre ong de défense des droits
des homosexuels
oui ce qui chez pas su redonner un matin
de mai 2021 c'est ce qui se passe au
cameroun depuis au moins 2005 2006 il y
a eu les associations curiosité
comment dirais je fais mais avec
beaucoup de brutalité policière
il y a les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme devant moi même qu'ils ont été
moi j'ai eu des lancers de pierres
assortie d'une émission j'ai eu des
blessures tué était le ministre de la
justice a demandé ma radiation auprès du
conseil de l'ordre et je ne vous dis pas
ce que les journalistes en paix en 2005
à qu'ils ont commencé à sortir la la
liste des personnalités supposées
homosexuels et ça a provoqué des taux
les énormes les familles ont été
bouleversés les enfants menacé de se
suicider qui voyait le nom de l'impasse
sur ces listes là et à ce moment là on
en a profité pour faire de l'homophobie
le pain quotidien des monnaies et est-ce
que globalement elle veut globalement
vous observez une violence d'état bien
orchestrée à l'encontre de la communauté
lgbt sur le continent
oui bien sûr
vous avez l'homosexualité et ça se sent
ce sont les gens du régime qui me l'ont
dit
ils ne sont pas foncièrement opposés
parce que eux-mêmes ont été la cible
d'un dôme pavois par voie médiatique
ciblés et à des ministres que rick est
désigné comme des homosexuels qui a été
obligé de porter plainte sous la
pression de leurs familles pour
démontrer qu'ils ne l'étaient pas donc
quand on me dit aujourd'hui que
l'homophobie c'est c'est celle où c'est
moi ou les même pas du tout eux mêmes
ont aidé mais simplement ils m'ont
expliqué que sur le plan politique ça
les dérange c'est une façon de
déstabiliser un adversaire politique
pendant la campagne anges et dans
l'opinion ne devrait être que si vous
voulez voter pour tel ou tel autre
candidat eh bien il va légaliser
l'homosexualité
alors là haut c'est qu'on peut lui faire
perdre des voix m comme on va marquer
une courte pause et se retrouver pour
poursuivre avec vous on se retrouve donc
dans un instant rester avec nous sur
arte france
[Musique]
retour dans afrique connect consacrés à
la lutte pour les droits de la
communauté lgbt nous sommes avec m à
alison comme avocate au cameroun
défenseurs des droits des homosexuels
m comme plus de la moitié des 54 pays
africains pénalise sanctionne réprime
durcissent voir criminalise même à
l'homosexualité quelques pays ont tout
de même choisi une voie inverse comme
l'afrique du sud l'angola le mozambique
le botswana les seychelles le gabon la
côte d'ivoire n'en gagne notamment à le
sénégal où le parlement a rejeté fin
2021 une proposition de loi visant à
durcir les peines de prison à l'encontre
des homosexuels
mais c'est vrai la bataille pour les
droits des homosexuels est loin d'être
gagnée on voit cela avec les à
l'occasion
il est bon que les états unis il est bon
que le canada
l'europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les valeurs en question l'homophobie en
décembre dernier au sénégal onze députés
de l'opposition ont déposé un projet de
loi visant à condamner les homosexuels à
10 ans de prison ferme soit le double de
la législation actuelle soutenue par les
associations et les confréries
religieuses le texte a finalement été
rejeté par le parlement mais dans ce
pays musulman à 95% les rapports avec
une personne de même sexe sont toujours
considérés comme contre nature est
criminalisé d'un emprisonnement allant
de 1 à 5 ans
aujourd'hui encore 31 pays d'afrique
réprime et condamnent l'homosexualité
pour quatre d'entre eux où la charia est
applicable la peine maximale encourue et
la mort par lapidation mais si l'on
remonte le fil de l'histoire la
législation anti gay trouve ses racines
dans le code pénal des anciennes
colonies imposé par l' empire
britannique au 19e siècle les lois
interdisant toute relation sexuelle à
visée non reproductive qualifié de crime
contre nature n'ont parfois jamais été
rediscuté un héritage que le nigeria a
même durci en se dotant des textes de
lois les plus répressives du continent
les soutiens affichés à la communauté
lgbt sont passibles de prison ferme
quand l'acte de sodomie est puni par
peine de mort la situation n'est pas
plus enviable pour les personnes courir
dans les pays à majorité chrétienne
comme le ghana la législation oblige
désormais ses citoyens à dénoncer les
comportements jugés suspects et interdit
tout rassemblement sur lequel pourrait
flotter un drapeau arc en ciel
à l'extrême sud du continent c'est une
tout autre atmosphère seul pays à
légaliser le mariage gay est ce plus de
dix ans avant l'allemagne les etats-unis
l'afrique du sud organise chaque année
depuis 1990 ça marche des fiertés
la beaucoup de personnes y auraient aimé
être ici mais en fin de compte
c'est comme si vous preniez des risques
juste pour manifester même dans un pays
qui reconnaît les droits des homosexuels
et pourtant les gens hésitent encore
parce qu'ils craignent que s'ils
retournent dans leur communauté
on leur fasse du mal
[Musique]
au kenya c'est historique le camp de
réfugiés de kakuma troisième plus grand
camp de réfugiés au monde a décidé
d'organiser la toute première gay pride
du pays en 2018
[Musique]
et paul allégués sont tellement obligé
de se cacher il est impossible pour eux
de se montrer pour des raisons évidentes
de sécurité de protection qui ici nous
nous considérons comme la voix des sans
voix c'est un peu un coming out qui a
pour but de sensibiliser les gens et de
leur montrer que nous n'avons rien de
dangereux nous sommes juste des êtres
humains
organisateurs du festival wamala bachir
a vu juste après l'événement de
participants ont été agressés et cette
menace a été placardée à l'entrée du
camp ce que vous êtes en train de faire
doit immédiatement cesser nous n'avons
rien dit jusqu'à présent vous devez
quitter le camp car vous avez sali notre
religion et nos enfants si vous ne
partez pas nous allons vous tuer les uns
après les autres ce n'est pas une blague
parfois plus intransigeante que la
justice la censure et la pression des
communautés religieuses devient monnaie
courante pour discriminer la communauté
lgbt au nom de la protection des moeurs
mettre une comme sur 54 pays 40
n'offrent aucune protection juridique
concernant le don que la communauté lgbt
cuit comment progresse les droits pour
les homosexuels sur le continent
je pense que ces droits doivent ils sont
condamnés à progresser dans le sens du
respect des droits de chacun
et la communauté internationale doit
être au premier rang de la défense de
7,2 de ses droits sans discrimination
c'est à dire le combat contre la
discrimination est un combat mondial
ce n'est pas une affaire les
associations locales ce n'est pas une
affaire de gouvernement qui par ailleurs
ont tous dans leur constitution je le
suppose comme le cameroun la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme qui
posent ces principes là qui sont devenus
des principes constitutionnels
il faudrait que les pays africains
sachent que ce n'est pas un honneur pour
la mère fille qui est la mère de
l'humanité
ce n'est pas un honneur de l'acculer à
pratiquer la discrimination entre tous
ces enfants ou alors qu'on nous dise
plus que la fille et la mère de
l'humanité il faut aussi rappeler que
l'homophobie tue en afrique de femmes
transsexuelles shakiro et patricia qui
ont été condamnés à cinq ans de prison
c'était en mai 2021 après leur
arrestation dans un restaurant c'est la
double punition très souvent puisque
plusieurs mois après leur placement en
liberté provisoire ces deux femmes ont
décrit des conditions de détention
inhumaines
oui c'est ça c'est exactement ça la
sphère chaque héros et patricia est
toujours en instance devant la cour
d'appel est déjà celle de jeu les
pauvres malheureux doit mieux cacher
comme des bêtes cliquer dans la société
qui est la leur et où ils ont le droit
elles ont le droit de demander la
protection légale
cheb khaled al même jusqu'à la cause des
tirs pour la constitution oblige le
présent de la république qui a prêté
serment sur elle de protéger tous ceux
citoyens et d'assurer la sécurité des
biens et de toutes les personnes sans
discrimination au ghana il ya une
nouvelle loi qui est débattu au
parlement elle prévoit notamment de
criminaliser cette fois la défense des
droits des personnes lgbt guillon va
écouter alex kochis condors de
l'association justement lgbt du vitrail
scan à
hydra notre bureau a été attaqué fermés
administrativement
il y habite nps qui ont présenté un
projet de loi au parlement c'était
l'année dernière
et
une date des eaux des lacs loi a pour
but de criminaliser les personnes qui
s'identifient comme lgbt cul et même à
inciter les familles à dénoncer des
personnes qu'elles perçoivent comme
courir si vite ils
souhaitent également criminaliser toute
forme de sympathie et de défense des
droits des lgbt cul dans le pays
ea et prévoit jusqu'à dix ans de prison
pour toute forme d'organisation qui
défend les droits des personnes lgbt cul
et pour tout activistes défenseur ou
même médecin avocat toute personne qui
fournit des services aux personnes lgbt
cul ou à une personne perçue comme telle
loi vise également ceux qui manifestent
une quelconque forme d'affection lgbt
dans la rue
elle donne aux familles la possibilité
de contrôler et de dénoncer tourner
membres de la famille qu'elle considère
comme une personne âgée bt cul ou qui a
tendance à l'être
cette loi vise également l'utilisation
de sex-toys et criminalise l'utilisation
de sex-toys
il s'agit donc de 36 pages de sanctions
très draconiennes et extrêmement sévère
à l'encontre non seulement des personnes
lgbt q mais aussi des sympathisants des
personnes lgbt qui
mettra comme je sais que vous aussi vous
quand lorsque vous plaidez vous arrive
de plaider accompagné de deux gardes du
corps vous êtes aussi sous le coup de
menaces de mort votre réaction à ce
projet de loi au ghana
c'est de la folie pure d'annaba où il
est devenu fou c'est une façon de
pénaliser l'amour en bois plus aimer
c'est plus pire que la gestapo cpie de
le nazisme mais le ghana a perdu la tête
qui se réveille un peu
c'est pas possible et sur le plan du
droit on ne pouvait pas pourrez vous
allez prouver quoi que ce que je fais
dans mon lit et et la vie privée et tous
ces grands principes universels mais
quelle législation la logan à ses deux
grand bond en arrière et dans
l'obscurantisme
il faut les réveiller faut que la
communauté internationale les interpelle
parce que je ne pense pas que ces lois
là puissent aller dans le sens des
principes défendus par l'onu place fut
magique est justement la communauté
internationale je sais que vous tentez
de la sensibiliser qu'elles sont comment
est-ce qu'elle réagit et quels sont
justement les mesures qui sont prises au
plus haut niveau dès de ses instances
internationales
je vais chez nous au calme ne nous ne
sommes pas un pays où on respecte
particulièrement les lois de la met
d'ailleurs nous au cameroun vous ne
pouvez pas ne pouvait pas
introduire une proposition de loi à
l'assemblée c'est seulement le
gouvernement lui-même introduit donc le
problème
tout est dans les mains du chef de
l'exécutif peut pas changer les choses
s'il décide de qui vend des années cette
loi
nous pouvons simplement attaqué sa
pavois incidente par les engagements que
le cameroun a pris au niveau de l'union
africaine parce qu'on me dit que c'est
pas efficace et pas qu'un mais nous
avons nous avons une résolution de la
commission africaine des droits de
l'homme qui dit que tous les pays
parties à la charte africaine des droits
de l'homme les principes de bâle vous
interdise de vous immiscer dans la rue
peel et au contraire vos a trait à la
respecter
vous oblige à mettre de côté toute
discrimination liée aux rougeurs ou au
sexe ou à la religion voit la pelote de
pau donc tous les pays qui criminalisent
l'homosexualité chez eux l'angle de
l'onu membres de la francophonie membres
de tous ces grandes organisations sont
en infraction par rapport aux charges
qui font d'eux les membres de ce clan
des divisions internationales politiques
et les politiques africains parce qu'on
sait aussi que cette communauté lgbt
cuistot s'il ya un électorat potentiel
oui mais pour les aider à ne pas perdre
leur clientèle ne peuvent pas et ne
peuvent pas aller se ajouté on va dire
ça
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le pays ici
chez moi en mes james a comme délit par
collet m
vous ne pouvez même pas en tant que
candidat dire que vous me pénaliser pas
l'homosexualité même si vous avez les
loyers juridiquement fort solide sur les
pressions religieuses on va écouter alex
a coffee condat
la pression exercée par les communautés
religieuses est incroyablement forte et
pour être honnête si l'on considère
l'homophobie cch connaissons
actuellement elle est principalement due
aux chefs religieux
les chefs religieux joue un rôle très
important dans l'homophobie et la haine
que nous subissons actuellement en tant
que communauté alors c'est vrai mais
train comme ailleurs dans le monde
certaines églises adopte une ligne de
conduite plus souple pourquoi c'est loin
d'être le cas sur le continent même s'il
faut citer quand même le travail
de l'archevêque desmond toutou qui nous
a quitté son travail pour lutter contre
l'homophobie
monseigneur monseigneur ginoux tout
n'était pas - - - - enseignants que
celui qui était homophobe d'un
catholique vous savez dans le monde il y
aura toujours des
des les despotes et aura toujours des
gens vous prépare à ce que dentiste et a
toujours des gens qui sont de vrais
humanistes quelle que soit la religion
vous voyez bien vous ne pourrez pas dire
aujourd'hui que vous luttez contre le
djihadisme et continuer à maintenir au
nom de la religion le mont phobie des
gars c'est pas possible tous les pays
dans lesquels en pratique sont en
contradiction avec le principe même de
l'état de droit et ne devait même pas
participé pas partie des instances
internationales et leur demander de
l'aide ossébi faut lutter contre le
diabète ils sont en totale contradiction
avec le même et avec leur signature à
rillieux voyez bien que ça ne tient pas
un délit un délit c'est quelque chose
qui cause un préjudice à autrui
comment est ce que dans les églises tous
les dimanches aimez vous les uns les
autres et venir au lieu que si vous
aimez plus topic y comme on le faisait à
l'époque tu ne dois pas aimer du noir et
blanc dans certains pays la même
tendance en prose si tu le vois pas aimé
notre job parce que tu es toi même nom
c'est là c'est le b à ba de la
contradiction c'est le manque de
cohérence à tiennent pas la route
et donc les jours les gens qui inclut
mentalise le monde oui à des fins
électoralistes
[Musique]
et bien sûr tout contre eux parce que
les catholiques aujourd'hui mais qui de
tous de lire leurs produits et des
soutiens qui viennent de l'extérieur
notamment du monde de la culture a
notamment on l'a vu après les événements
au ghana en 2021 il ya aussi des
initiatives notamment je pense à celle
du président américain joe biden
détendre justement la protection des
droits lgbt dans le monde entier en
utilisant justement le les sanctions
financières mais ça c'est mal vu aussi
du côté des pays africains on crie à l'
ingérence ont créé à l'impérialisme
quelle est la solution pour terminer est
ce qu'il faut faire finalement
qu'est maurice il peut pas vouloir le
beurre et la jungle de
calais gérard ce sont le temps qu'ils
sont les premiers à aller chercher la
france aussi aller chercher l'angleterre
pour ça aller chercher les états unis où
il veut pas être majeur et veulent pas
être autonome s'ils sont toujours là a
demandé à la chine a partout partout
partout pas alors comment est-ce qu'il
peut parler de l'élite agira gens les
patrons de la demande les gérants
tout et qu'ils sachent ce qu'ils veulent
et c'est comme ça ils vont transformer
bientôt le l'apic en champ de bataille
pour la troisième guerre mondiale qui te
plaît pas
c'est comme ça qu'ils vont signer
tamponner les blacks qui font que le
plan de route la fille que je retourne
plusieurs millénaires à l'arrière
parce qu'un possible de s'attendre sur
les vraies valeurs l'homophobie n'est
pas une valeur tu désolé en contrebas le
merci beaucoup à malheur chez l'amour
merci beaucoup à vous mettre à alison
cram merci
merci beaucoup de votre journée et merci
aux équipes du mag et techniques pour la
préparation de cette émission retrouver
à free connecte sur nos réseaux sociaux
et notre site rt france point tv merci
de votre attention à très bientôt dans
matri connecte sur rt france